LAWSUITS AS HE DID.
>> Laura: YOU'RE THE ONE PERSON
THAT I ENJOY CORRECTING ME.
>> WE HAVE DIFFERENT LAWS IN THE
STATE OF ARIZONA THAN IN
FLORIDA.
FLORIDA DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
MAIL-IN BALLOTS TO BE DROPPED
OFF AT VOTING LOCATIONS ON
ELECTION DAY.
FLORIDA EARLY VOTING CLOSES THE
SUNDAY BEFORE ELECTION DAY.
FLORIDA HAS A SHORTER PERIOD FOR
VOTERS TO CURE SIGNATURES.
>> Laura: WHAT IS IT WITH PEOPLE
WITH THE NAME BILL GATES?
THAT'S THE MARICOPA COUNTY
SUPERVISOR CHAIRMAN.
BILL GATES.
INADVERTENTLY REVEALED THE
SOLUTION.
JOINING ME NOW, FLORIDA SENATOR
MARCO RUBIO.
HE KNEW PRETTY EARLY ON ELECTION
NIGHT THAT HE CRUSHED HIS
OPPONENT, VAL DEMINGS TO
VICTORY.
HUGE WIN.
SENATOR, CONGRATULATIONS.
WERE YOU SURPRISED THAT ELECTION
OFFICIAL DISMISSED FLORIDA LIKE
SAYING YOU WANT US TO BE GREAT,
BUT YOU COMPARE US TO FLORIDA.
HE WAS REALLY ANNOYED BY THAT.
>> YEAH, HE'S ANNOYED BY BEING
COMPARED TO THAT STATE THAT
COUNTED 7.7 MILLION VOTES IN
FIVE HOURS.
THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
A VOTENER FLORIDA, WHEN YOU
VOTE, YOU KNOW YOUR VOTE HAS
BEEN COUNTED.
YOU CAN GO ONLINE AND MAKE SURE
YOUR BALLOT HAS BEEN RECEIVED
AND COUNTED.
THERE'S ALMOST A MONTH PERIOD
FOR MAIL BALLOTS.
THEY HAVE TO BE IN BY A CERTAIN
DATE.
MOST COUNTIES HAVE ALMOST TWO
WEEKS OF EARLY VOTING.
WE HAVE AN ELECTION DAY PROCESS.
WE KNEW BEFORE THEY ANNOUNCED
THE VOTE AMOUNT WHO GOT WHAT, WE
ALREADY KNEW BY 7:05 BECAUSE OF
THE TRANSPARENCY, HOW MANY VOTES
HAD BEEN COST IN THE STATE.
FLORIDA, WE STILL HAVE OVERSEAS
BALLOTS.
THEY HAVE SEVEN DAYS TO GET
HERE.
BEYOND THAT, THERE'S NO MYSTERY.
YOU'LL KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
THE KEY IS THE TRANSPARENCY.
SO YOU MAY FIGHT AGAINST WHY
SOMEONE LOST AN ELECTION OR WHY
SOMEONE WON AN ELECTION, BUT
NOBODY HAS TO BE WORRIED ABOUT
300,000 BALLOTS SAYING OH, 48
HOURS LATER BUT WE STILL HAVE
300,000 BALLOTS THAT CAME IN
YESTERDAY AND ANOTHER 50,000 MAY
COME TOMORROW.
THEY'VE CREATED LIKE TWO CLASS
OF VOTERS.
THE PEOPLE THAT VOTE UNDER
CERTAIN RULES AND PEOPLE THAT
DECIDE I'M GOING TO VOTE AFTER I
HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT THE OUTCOME
IS AND INJECT CHAOS IN TO THE
SYSTEM.
IT'S SAD.
BUT OUR LAWS IN FLORIDA WERE NOT
ALWAYS THIS WAY.
IT WAS THE PRODUCT OF TRIAL AND
ERROR.
WE HAD MISTAKES AND PROBLEMS.
WE HAD FEE AGAINST COS IN 2018
IN BROWARD AND PALM BEACH
COUNTIES.
OUR LAWS HAVE IMPROVED AND
LESSONS THAT I HOPE THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY WILL LEARN OR WE'LL
HAVE MORE NIGHTS LIKE WE HAVE IN
ARIZONA.
>> Laura: FINALLY, WHAT DOES THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY GET TO LEARN
OVER WHAT HAPPENED THE LAST FEW
YEARS IN FLORIDA?
>> THE OLDER REPUBLICAN PARTY
CAN WIN SOME ELECTIONS FROM TIME
TO TIME IN A FEW PLACES.
A NEW REPUBLICAN PARTY CAN
COMPETE AMONG ANYONE ANYWHERE.
IT'S A PARTY GROUNDED IN COMMON
SENSE AND WISDOM.
SHOULD BE FIGHTING FOR WORKING
CLASS VALUES, SHOULD BE PUTTING
THE INTEREST OF AMERICANS FIRST.
THE BEST THING I SAID THIS
ELECTION NIGHT, THE BEST THING
WE CAN DO FOR THE WORLD IS MAKE
AMERICA STRONG AS POSSIBLE.
THAT'S THE BEST THING WE CAN DO
FOR THE WORLD.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE MANY
PEOPLE IN BOTH PARTIES,
PARTICULARLY THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THAT ARE TELLING US THAT
BEFORE WE CARE ABOUT AMERICANS,
WE HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF PEOPLE
THAT COME HERE ILLEGALLY, WHAT
DEAL TO CUT AT THE U.N. CLIMATE
SCAM.
WORKING AMERICANS ARE BEING TOLD
WE HAVE TO PUT SOMEONE ELSE
SOMEWHERE ELSE AHEAD OF YOU.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT FIGHTS
FOR WORKING PEOPLE IS A PARTY
THAT HAS A CHANCE TO COMPETE
ANYWHERE AMONG ANY GROUP IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: YOUR VICTORY, SENATOR,
WAS STUNNING.
WE CONGRATULATE YOU.
YOU FOUGHT HARD FOR THAT.
YOU DEFEATED A FUTURE DEMOCRAT
STAR.
THAT'S WHAT MI